[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight every cult has the same goal the
utter submission of its members cult
members surrender everything they give
up their physical freedom where they can
go who they can see how they can dress
but more than that they give up control
of their minds cult leaders determine
what their followers are allowed to
believe even in their most private
thoughts in order to do this cult
separate people from all they have known
before they force their members to
renounce their former lives their
countries their customs they allow no
loyalty except to the cult the first
thing they attack always is the family
families are the main impediment to
brainwashing and extremism that's true
in every culture so if you're gonna
control individuals if you're gonna
transform free people into compliant
robots the first thing you must do is
separate them from the ones who love
them most
in 1932 Soviet authorities began
promoting the story of a 13 year old
peasant boy called Pavlich more Azov
more Azov they claimed had taken the
supremely virtuous step of denouncing
his own father to the secret police for
committing counter-revolutionary acts
once exposed as a traitor the boy's
father was executed by firing squad for
the safety of the state Joseph Stalin
elevated this boy to the status of
national hero for what he did people
wept in the streets when they heard his
name they worshipped him like a saint
why are we telling you this because it's
happening here in the last 10 days some
of our most prominent citizens have
sworn allegiance to a cult converts go
by the term allies and like all cult
members they demand total conformity
they ritually condemn their own nation
its history it's institutions its
symbols its flag they denounce their own
parents if you've been on social media
recently you've likely seen many videos
like this one
[Music]
I'm sorry you guys that is a child
attacking her mother and father for the
crime of insufficient loyalty to black
lives matter
reporter Hanna Lustig of insider.com
wrote about that video and she strongly
approved of it what you just saw a
Lustig wrote is a young person quote
modeling the most important tenant of a
lie ship modeling meaning something done
to encourage others to do the same it's
effective and in this case it's working
here's a fifteen-year-old from Louisiana
called Isabella there are many like her
in America right now they argue with me
that George Floyd these racism is
believed I hate my family so much just a
week ago would have been hard to imagine
that now isabella is a social media star
celebrities tweet their approval at her
she may have her own cult following
before long but the revolution is young
children attacking their parents is just
the beginning on CNN today a man called
Tim Wise told viewers that going forward
parents must hurt their own children I
think the important thing for white
parents to keep in the front of our mind
is that if black children in this
country are not allowed innocence and
childhood without fear of being killed
by police or marginalized in some other
way then our children don't deserve
innocence if Tamir rice can be shot dead
in a public park playing with a toy gun
something white children do all over
this country every day without the same
fear of being shot
if Tamir rice can be killed then white
children need to be told at least at the
same age if they can't be
we don't get to be innocent your
children are no longer allowed to be
innocent says Tim Wise happy childhoods
are a sign of racism the man saying this
and being affirmed by CNN's anchors as
he does is a self-described anti-racism
activist he's been saying things like
this for a long time more than once Tim
Wise has suggested that he approves of
violence against those who disagree how
does Tim Wise make a living well in part
by lecturing students your kids may have
seen him speak you've almost certainly
heard a lot of people like Tim Wise in
America's schools the revolution has
been in progress for quite some time
Rochester School District in New York
has created a black lives matter themed
lesson plan the teaching materials
dismiss America's bedrock institutions
indeed America itself as inherently
racist suggested questions for students
include how does mass incarceration
function as a mechanism of racialized
social control one specific racial group
is singled out for exclusive blame the
curriculum promotes a book entitled
white rage the unspoken truth of our
racial divide in other words children
there's a reason hatred and inequality
exists these people did it that's what
your kids are learning right now that's
not an overstatement
yesterday at darienne High School in
Connecticut principal Ellen Dunn sent an
email to parents in which she promised
to increase the quote race-conscious
education of our students in order to
achieve that done distributed materials
from the Southern Poverty Law Center now
ironically the Southern Poverty Law
Center is itself a hate group that has
been documented extensively but now
their agenda is the school's agenda it's
what your kids are learning in
Washington DC an elementary school
principal in the affluent Northwest
section of the city recently wrote a
letter announcing that quote we need
more white parents to talk to their kids
about race especially now the letter
singled out quote white staff and white
community members whom the principal
alleged had committed quote both macro
and micro aggressions against staff of
color the principal did not specify what
those crimes were she didn't need to
their skin color was there
time this is a national theme it pains
us to tell you that but it's true it's
incredibly destructive and dangerous
Kalwa school districts are now using the
1619 project from the New York Times for
example as a curriculum that project is
the work of an out of the closet racial
extremists called Nicole Hannah Jones
Jones for example recently argued it is
not violence to loot and burn stores is
justified her propaganda is now
mandatory in public schools in Buffalo
Chicago Newark Washington many parents
understandably deeply resent this
it's deranged it's racist but others
don't they are allies and they've joined
in one mother in London where the cult
is also spreading posted this photo on
Twitter it's of her daughter on bended
knee holding a sign declaring her
privilege the Cultural Revolution has
come to the west well the effects of
this be this is just a moment it will
end
how will we feel about it looking back
years from now how will that little girl
with the sign remember her childhood her
mother took Tim wisest advice she no
longer has innocence will she be
grateful for that it's hard to imagine
she will be more likely she will feel
bitter and used because she has been
used and it's likely that many children
growing up right now will feel the same
way is there a single person who
believes that this moment we're living
through will end in racial harmony that
used to be what we wanted some of us
still do want that is it even a goal
anymore it doesn't seem like it instead
it seems like many empowers very clear
in fact that many in power are pushing
hard for racial division for hatred for
violence and let's pray they don't get
what they want
tribal conflict will destroy a country
faster than any plague but keep in mind
as this insanity continues that it
doesn't happen in a vacuum
every action provokes a reaction that's
physics we don't know where this is
going we don't want to know where it's
going the cult members should stop now
immediately before more innocence get
hurt and they will if they don't